bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors l'afrique du sud
vient de l'annoncer 1 a dépassé le pic
de la quatrième vague le pic du variant
omicron un mois après l'apparition du
virus c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour
le pays
puis c'était très moche et était très
bonne nouvelle pour nous parce que on a
commencé la fiq omicron le 27 novembre
et on a vu
99 morts étaient les plus nombreux pour
pour ça tous les jours maintenant et à
ce moment là on a eu de 31 mille cas
nouveaux cas par jour mais maintenant
s'abaisser jusqu'à 7000 cas par jour et
là taux de mortalité saleh jusqu'à 25
morts c'est le 20/08 descendante tendent
un seul mois on a dépassé le pic de home
itron et c'est heureusement c'est
beaucoup très légère pour nous et il y a
très peu et des gens soins intensifs qui
souffre du coc vide en ce moment à
grasse je crois c'est un cadeau du coc
vie pour nous pour le monde entier parce
que maintenant on a une immunité à
immunité comme unitaire qui se devait le
toit
à travers le monde alors en afrique du
sud on a donc une vague courtin très
courte elle a commencé le 27 novembre on
est le 31 décembre on a des taux
d'hospitalisation plus faible que lors
des baguettes précédente qu'est ce que
ça peut nous dire pour l'europe qui est
en état d' alerte en justement à cause
de mikron
mais il faut toujours garder je crois
que les gens qui sont obèses qui ont les
tensions artérielles qui soufflait dit
abete est ce toujours au risque de trucs
d'avoir le que vida c'est plus ouvert
mais même en afrique du sud les gens
qu'il n'était pas encore vaccinée parce
que le temps de la vaccination en
afrique du sud les jeux se laisse
jusqu'à 36% on n'est pas si vacciner
koné enduro mais malgré tout cela on
avait encore et trouver les mots qu on a
attendez donc je crois que vous allez
sortez assez bien
vague aux micros mems en angleterre il y
a
ah c'est très peu de morts parce qu'ils
ont eue je crois sont 150 mille cartes
par jour mais malgré
les nombreux des cas en les taux de
mortalité est faible
vous dire vous parlez de la vaccination
en afrique du sud on rappelle on a une
couverture vaccinale sur ps qui est très
faible en tout cas comparer à celle qui
a en europe la prudence reste donc de
mise
je conseille de continuer les paris a
jugé ce même on a dépêché le couvre-feu
parce qu'on peut sortir après minuit
mais on est toujours le truc est
conseillé d éviter les les beaucoup de
gens qui sinon les petites pièces et de
rester plutôt d or et un garde et pelé
10 ans même après tout le mali des la
maladie m'a dit d'y aller le week-end
variant et s'est légèrement c'est très
légère que je trouvais auparavant
apparemment pas revendre en variant
delta j'avais je m'occupais de 70
malades et la plupart 2e était le co
vite et les plupart des mets malade est
en soins intensifs dans les derniers
mois j'avais eu 25 malades il n'y avait
qu'à 3 qui a eu le coc vie il ya un
parmi les trois qui étaient seules
oxygène les autres étaient très
tranquille dans les salles donc vous en
tant que nos homologues
johannesburg qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire que le variant omicron et
certaines ont plus contagieux que les
autres variant mais moins virulent
oui tout à fait c'est trois fois plus
qu'en très contagieux mais heureusement
c'est pas à pas si violent que les
autres les autres vagues donc pour moi
c'est ça va répondre très vite à travers
l'europe entière mais il y avait
beaucoup qui va qui va avoir une
immunité parce qu'on ne sait on on sait
qu'il ya d'autres vara qui va venir mais
heureusement avec chaque mutation ceux
qui sont infectés va garder une unité
entre arias
mais c'est pas 100% mais au moins avec
chaque changement on a une unité qui
s'installe dans la population alors pour
terminer en tête sur une touche positive
le couvre feu nocturne a donc été levée
en afrique du sud peut espérer une
relance économique
oui tout à fait et je crois
que l'europe doit suivre l'exemple de
l'afrique du sud c'est inutile de
accabler la plan économique pour les
gens il faut ouvre les foules
les entreprises et d'arrêter de faire
des couvre feux qui vaquaient vraiment
tuer le
d'économique dans ce pays
merci beaucoup à l'âne peter ont d'abord
est avec nous sur rt france rappelle que
vous êtes un peu nos homologues à
l'hôpital de sault est de soweto vous
étiez donc en direct avec nous d'afrique
du sud merci à vous